- [Bryan N.] Huge NFL fan.
What's up J, what's up?
- Hello, hello everyone.
- [Congregation] Hey, how are ya?
- I am well.
- [Bryan N.] Good.
- How are you?
- [Bryan N.] Good, thanks.
- Good.
How's it going so far?
- [Bryan N.] Great, fantastic.
- Well.
- [Bryan N.] A lotta stuff.
- There is a lot of stuff.
Okay, great, I'd love to go around,
introduce yourself, where
you're from and what you do,
and then we'll go back
around and do Q and A,
and I would make that very
selfish because that's,
you know, you get you
consume plenty of macro,
free advice from me,
but I'd love to make sure
I deliver on what your
singular question is here.
So, let's go.
This portion is like, with me,
so I think this is when
you need to get selfish.
Like you need to ask your question.
(lively music)
Hiring is guessing.
Firing is knowing.
Like, you gotta go fast.
That's how you get shit done.
That's how you figure stuff out.
This is the television,
and the television is the radio.
For four Ds, motherfuckers.
- [Bryan B.] Bryan Bellamy,
from Charlotte, North Carolina,
Head of The Refinery Haus,
which is a small agency right now.
- Awesome.
- So, yeah, good to see you
- [Stephen] My name is Stephen Jayne,
Refinery Haus, Charlotte, North Carolina.
Paid media.
- Paid media.
- And I'm Taylor Bryant,
Creative Director at the Refinery Haus.
- Awesome.
- Mark I know you, I know you, I know you.
(laughing)
Okay, here we go.
Go ahead, it's not your turn.
- [Carrie] I'm Carrie.
We are The One Percent Group with Linh.
So a lot of partner and business partner.
- Very nice.
- [Carrie] We're from
Melbourne, Australia.
- [Linh] We work with
health and fitness experts
to help them monetize on their brand.
Really niche health and fitness experts,
postnatal, your body building
guys, power lifting guys,
all sorts of, just real experts
that can solve one problem.
We help them generate leads, makes sales,
set up their delivery systems to scale,
creating a high-end experience
for their customers and clients.
- Understood.
Through a rev-share with them
model or through a fee model?
- [Carrie] At the moment,
fees.
- [Man] Fee model.
- Understood.
Awesome.
- [Doug] So my name is Doug Williams.
I am the founder of Grand Factor Inc,
and basically I am a personal CTO.
So, I help solo entrepreneurs,
small businesses,
when they're struggling
and trying to scale
and they're frustrated,
I go in and basically
build their tech stacks
or help them with automation for that one.
- Makes a lot of sense.
Where you based?
- [Doug] D.C.
- Awesome.
- [Doug] Yeah, yeah.
- Very cool.
- [Doug] And then
started with copywriting.
So that's how it started years
ago and then went from there.
- Interesting, okay.
- [Bryan N.] Bryan Neale.
CEO of Blind Zebra Enterprises.
I do sales training, sales
coaching, keynote speaking,
and podcasting.
My side hustles, I'm an NFL ref.
- Is that true?
- [Bryan N.] That's true.
I got you a present too.
- I'm fired up about it.
I want it already.
- [Bryan N.] You want the present?
- No, we'll save it for the end.
- [Bryan N.] All right, we'll do it later.
- You NFL ref?
- [Bryan N.] I'm an NFL ref, yeah.
- You actually referee NFL games?
I think it's amazing.
- [Bryan N.] For five years.
You've seen me officially
and not even know.
- That's crazy.
That's amazing.
- [Bryan N.] Right, it's awesome.
- How many games a year do you do?
- [Bryan N.] 22.
15 regular season, four
pre-season hopefully.
- I'm so fired up.
I cannot wait to be mad at a
call that you make next year.
- [Bryan N.] You can
ask anything you want.
I know we got the cameras going.
We gotta stay neutral.
- Listen, I already know the answers.
It's human beings, you know.
It's like, it's amazing.
Cool, that's really cool.
Let's rock and roll.
- [Bryan B.] All right, Q and A, so--
- So, in the macro, actually
I'll just start with this,
given you three, I would
assume, which would be smart,
given what you're at, creative and media,
you're on your path to building
a VaynerMedia-like agency
and trying to figure--
I mean obviously there's always nuances,
but creative and media under one house,
and you're trying to, whatever it may be.
There may be a bunch of different things.
- I don't know if you
remember, I left you a comment
about asking about how
you apply a retainer model
to a software development agency,
and so that's like
primary is solving this.
So, we have a software development agency
that sits next to a
digital marketing agency.
So, they're all from the
digital marketing agency side.
We also have full service
software development
in terms of, I mean,
enterprise all this stuff.
So--
- All under--
- [Bryan B.] One brand.
- One company?
Like one P&L?
- [Bryan B.] Yep.
- Okay.
- [Bryan B.] Um, and--
- It started with that and
this has been built on top?
- [Bryan B.] That's correct.
Yeah, so it's software
development goes back
about four and 1/2 years.
- How did that start?
- [Bryan B.] Me.
- Solo?
- [Bryan B.] Pretty much.
- Cool.
- [Bryan B.] Yep,
and then, so--
- How many people are in each?
- [Bryan B.] So almost, a
bench of about 70 engineers
on the right side with--
- Meaning none full-time
and all outsource,
when you say bench?
- [Bryan B.] So, I invested
in an agency in St. Louis,
so that we could share an engineer bench.
- Interesting.
So they're full-time employees?
- [Bryan B.] They're full-time of them
and then we get to, I get
to lean into their bench
and kinda call share.
- I get it.
- [Bryan B.] So easy, versatile capacity.
Keeps my overhead low.
- Totally understand.
- [Bryan B.] So--
- So that's that.
How many, if any, full-time DEV?
- [Bryan B.] Full-time DEVs?
- Yeah.
- [Bryan B.] Just over a dozen.
- Understood.
- [Bryan B.] And then,
kind of, on this side,
we're all full-time in the agency.
- And how many of those?
- [Bryan B.] About a dozen as well.
Well 10 to 15, yeah.
- Cool.
- [Bryan B.] So, on the software side,
I'm curious if you've seen models work
where you can have a retainer
that's more than just support
or maintenance, right?
'Cause you've talked about
breaking out the strategy
into its own component
of how you bill a client,
or like management--
- The answer's you can,
and you've gone through
some of these things.
It's hard for it not to
be support or maintenance
because people have bought
into the value of that.
- [Bryan B.] Right.
- You know when I started VaynerMedia,
this company started as
community management only.
That was the only thing we did.
You know, Campbell's hired us and,
some of you are youngsters,
but old Facebook,
like if you left somebody
on somebody's page,
that was what was on top of the wall.
It was like MySpace, you know?
So, people weren't like, the
amount of people that laughed
me out of the room to make comments,
to do community management
and make content,
which is the core foundation of who I am
and what is probably
considered best in class 2019
marketing on digital right now.
Put out content on social networks
and engage with the community
for insights and, right?
Laughed out of the room
for $5,000 a month.
with a million followers on Twitter,
when I knew him,
when built up Wine Library with like,
been on Conan,
with like the same kid that
built from three to 60 million,
laughed.
Why I'm telling you
that is it's the answer.
The answer is of course.
If you deliver on what
you're asking for in return,
and I believe there are
a lot of people emerging,
potentially, in the mid
market that can afford
to pay a strategy around
tech infrastructure.
I think both of you can
easily convince a human
and say, "Hey Gary,
you have Wine Library."
Let's go back to my
dad's own store and say,
you're wasting money on legacy, tech
and bad infrastructural decisions
by just paying me $3,000 a month,
where I will both be in
the bat phone business,
so before you decide if
it's Mailchimp or Cloud this
or Google, like, or a new PO--
If you just, a bat phone,
and on top of that I'll be proactive,
and set up, off,
I'll be in defense, bat phone,
but quarterly we have an in-face
or a 30 minute call every two months
or I'll be on offense where
me and my team are thinking
about your liquor store business
and you build an
infrastructure that allows
people to see what's
going on best in class.
In Canada, the Canada
Liquor Control Board,
now puts QR codes on their bottles.
I do believe that there's a sector
that would pay for thinking.
- [Bryan B.] Okay.
- Because the way you always
get people to understand it
is the money saved.
One of the ways I started breaking through
to community management was saying,
"How much do you spend on call centers?"
"Oh, fucking, millions."
I'm like, they blow,
and they do nothing.
Community management,
when somebody goes on your
Campbell's page and
says you're soup stinks,
that also could be a call center,
and we're only 60,000 for the year,
and I'm gonna pay--
Got it?
So it's the angle.
- [Bryan B.] Guess it's like the product
or the story that you present to them.
- I gave it to you.
I think that's the truth.
I mean, I'm sure there's others,
but I gave you the one that, like,
I'm always reverse
engineer from the consumer,
I always say, "What would trick me?"
And trick in a good way.
What would get me thinking, like, hmm?
And one thing you could do is,
if you go prospecting it's like,
do you spend $50,000 a year on technology?
Technology is your email service, your--
Like you throw a lot in there.
My dad's company, Wine Library, right now,
is incapable of making
smart tech decision.
Ah, that's not true, I
forgot we have John K.,
no, we are,
but a lot aren't,
and more importantly, bless you,
and John would know what
to do with that too.
So, people don't like to pay for thinking.
They don't like it.
Strategy is (groans),
but--
- [Linh] We just started
on the marketing side
and it's gone great.
- Because there's an output along with it.
Strategy baked into videos, cool.
Strategy just for the sake
of strategy, not cool.
Got it?
- [Linh] Yeah.
- Notice how I made you put
something tangible in there.
I'm gonna give you a 30 minute
call every nine, you know.
So people want some, you know, something.
I'll be honest with you,
one of the ways to do it
is to do an annual conference.
- [Bryan B.] Interesting.
- Yeah, one of the
things we're about to do
at VaynerSports, just
to give you a preview,
you'll see me promoting it in six months.
I got to get it past AJ,
but I think I got it.
(group laughing)
We have a lot of people
that are doing brand
deals with our players,
but so much of it has to be do with me
and they're trying to, and I'm like,
look, why don't we just,
if they do brand deals with our partners,
like with our players,
why don't we do a thing every year
like the Saturday before the Super Bowl
in whatever town it is,
and they get access to
that one day full of it,
it's money to spend time
with me and it is an hour.
- [Bryan B.] We did pilot it in Atlanta
this year a little bit.
- Yeah, what we did in Atlanta is exactly
how I'm thinking about it.
Atlanta that was the fucking cool party
and I'll do that again.
In Miami, we'll have 2
Chainz and we'll have,
we'll kill it and it'll be culture.
That's Saturday night.
Friday, will be the business conference
for the people that
signed $1,000 deal or more
with VaynerSports people
and what those businesses are gonna do
and be like fuck it.
I don't give a fuck who VaynerSports gives
to what players my money
for my cheese puffs.
I just wanna be with Gary
for that day on Friday.
I would pay,
got it?
That's how you have to think,
reverse engineer them.
[Bryan B.] Mmm-hmm, makes sense, okay.
And then, kind of the reason
why we came or I brought them
is we're a really young marketing agency,
really young, January 1 of this year.
- Amazing, congrats.
- [Bryan B.] Thanks.
So it's more of starting well for us,
versus coming to you in two years going,
shit, I wasted hours
on this hours on that.
- That's right, that's exactly right.
- [Bryan B.] If you can
go back to where you,
if you even were every in
between 10 and 20 full-timers--
- We were.
- [Bryan B.] and like boutique
and uh--
- I started my company
in a conference room
of another company.
- [Bryan B.] Beautiful.
- Like we were, like people
kind of continue to forget
that--
- [Bryan B.] No, I knew you
started from ground zero.
- Ground zero.
- [Bryan B.] You're like a 30 friends or--
- Got it.
- [Bryan B.] 10 friends.
- No, respect.
We were small,
- [Bryan B.] Cool.
- for a long time 'cause
the first two years,
I was pretty passive.
I think when I took over
two and 1/2 years in,
I think we were less than 30.
- [Bryan B.] That's awesome.
- Yeah, we got crazy when I
started running it full-time.
I just love hiring people.
(group laughing)
That's not a joke.
So, go ahead.
- [Bryan B.] Yeah, so if
you can think back to then,
give me, I mean--
- Couple core things,
disproportionate over communication
with every single person that's in it.
- [Bryan B.] Excellent.
The game changing reason why VaynerMedia
is still foundationally strong
is how close I was to
the first 100 employees.
It's still permeates.
(mumbles) said later
of like old Vayner new,
there's many things that
will come from it later,
but it is the, honestly
it's raising a child.
Over love the fuck out of your kid
in the first four years and
see ridiculous dividends later.
Later, you can worry about entitlement,
but at four, they can't be entitled,
just love the fuck out of them.
Later, you can not let them win,
like I do with them now.
You know?
And they'll cry like, does everyday,
but because they're getting used to like,
"What is this?"
You know?
So, your the guy?
- [Bryan B.] Mmm-hmm.
- You have to build a real relationship
with all of them.
Thanks for the post you posted yesterday.
That's very sweet.
You have to build a real relationship
and you have to manage
all of them differently.
You have to manage them based on them,
not based on you.
- [Bryan B.] Right, yeah.
- And at first, everyone wants,
there's a million things.
At 12 and 20, you're gonna
have that awesome culture.
People are gonna stay later.
You're close as fuck.
Cut out the cancer quick.
If you by accident, fucked
up and hired somebody.
You gotta give her or him,
the only time I'm pretty radical candor
is when there's a singular
cancer in a small group,
where I'm like, "Hey, nobody likes you."
"Well I'm the best employee".
I'm like, "Cool, I'm
still gonna fire you."
The best employee isn't the
one who makes the most money
or the client likes the best.
It's the holistic best
and all 11 people in this office
don't love the way you're rolling.
- [Bryan B.] Makes sense.
- So, that's important,
early cancer's important,
'cause it keeps positive vibes.
It's a very, I think the
first four years of a company
are disproportionally nurturing.
It's actually really funny.
There was a period in 2011, 12,
when I was investing in pretty heavily
in female-centric startups.
You know, Birchbox and McMag
and all these companies,
and later, it became such
a part of our culture.
There was a moment 24 months ago,
where what's your portfolio look like
with female founders and I
could see it was bubbling up,
and I remember thinking,
this is gonna be awesome
because I was really in a good place,
but it was really funny.
I was in a good place,
not by being a noble man
or trying to be fair,
it was out of my general
thesis of the other way.
It was my disresp--
It was my, uh,
It was me being, uh,
what's the word I'm looking for?
- [Someone In Background]
Disproportionate?
- No, sorry I used the word.
It was me being, I was stereotyping men.
Even though I'm a nurturing dude,
I was stereotyping men for not being,
I was being very basic.
"Women are," you know?
But I actually believe it.
I believe
that over nurturing emotionally a business
in the first three to four years
is remarkably underrated.
All feelings, all Kumbaya.
I mean, you've gotta pay the bills.
You gotta get through,
but I think that's where if you can help,
and I don't know you well enough,
if you can put a lot of
financial onus on yourself,
and right, it's very cliche.
That's why I asked you,
did you start it first?
I'm like, good, he's
gonna be able to do this
'cause he was, when you're the person
that is the thing at first, you know it.
You can't imagine how fun it
is to walk through this company
knowing that me as a CO
is the best practitioner
of social media work.
There is no executive that I'm
scared of in my own company.
(laughing)
It's very powerful.
Most executives lose touch with reality
or never had it in the first place.
They just thought of business idea
and their partner was the
one that made the bread.
You know?
So, as much onus and pressure on you
to allow to establish that culture,
and then, where I missed the mark
was in year five, six, some--
When, when we were here.
When did we first move in here?
Three?
- [Assistant] Two to three
years ago.
- [Woman In Background] Yeah.
- Three right, three, it's three.
Three will be in August, right?
Yeah, yeah, so what are we in '19?
'16 I took over, five years in,
I did it so, I waited one year too long
to make the transition from
over nurturing to merit,
which then it creates entitlement,
and I had a very difficult
time unwinding that.
It took me a good year and a 1/2
because I let go of 30 people
to make this statement.
Rip the bandaid.
That fucked up every--
I mean, you would've thought
that it was The Great Depression in here.
The people yelling at
me in an all hands on,
and my own employees
being like, "Fuck you."
I made the mistake.
I waited a year, a year
and a 1/2 too long.
- [Bryan B.] To go from lovey-dovey
to like, "Hey, its a meritocracy."
- I make fun of entitlement.
Don't let your kids win
eighth place trophies,
but I missed the mark here
by a year, a year and a 1/2,
and the moment I realized it,
I just remember going
through that in my own mind.
I was like, this is gonna suck
because what entitled kids don't like
is when you cut off their
credit card (laughs).
The kids that you buy a
Mercedes for in high school,
pay for their college, unlimited
Uber, unlimited Equinox
and the first year out of college,
you buy them their apartment
and you get them unlimited Uber continuous
and you got them their job when you decide
'cause you're a parent that decides that
for some weird reason.
23 is the year a kid gets cut off.
That kid fuckin' shits on you like crazy
'cause you didn't condition them.
- [Byran B.] Yeah I have a little sister.
So, I'm well aware.
(laughing)
- So, that happens.
So, I think if you get,
that to me is the framework.
If you can get your timing right
from over coddling culture, safety, yes,
mmm, heart
and you can make that transition to merit,
and every company's different,
every leader's different.
I missed the mark here, which I will hope
will make me not miss
the mark the next time,
but here's why I do it,
I missed the mark
and our companies never
been healthier today.
Over correcting from when you
created too much entitlement
is a hell of a lot better
than establishing a company
that is a soulless, financial machine.
- [Congregation] Yeah.
You're never injecting culture into that.
So, the seed matters.
- [Bryan B.] Excellent.
- Cool.
- [Bryan B.] And then so, in
terms of over communication,
so for the first in college all the way
'till I exited my first business,
I was pretty much solo,
and so--
- It doesn't come natural.
- [Bryan B.] Right.
- Try to figure out your way.
Maybe it's phone calls.
Maybe it's hiring a chief heart officer,
making an investment to culture now,
and giving her or him
disproportionate power.
- [Bryan B.] Yeah, I'm excited for Claude.
- You know?
- [Bryan B.] Yeah.
- Cool.
- [Stephen] I wanna know a little bit more
of how do you guys manage your accounts
because there's a time
when you're younger,
younger company,
and you have an analyst
managing 10 accounts, right,
and then how do you go
about making that transition
into one-to-one or two-to-one?
- Carefully.
(laughing)
And when you are asking that,
are you asking financially
or how the account gets used to it
or the people themselves?
Give me the, all of the above?
- [Stephen] I think the easiest answer
would be the financial.
Well, they pay more, therefore
they get more people,
- Yes.
- [Stephen] but more of
like a part of the company
and culture because it's two
completely different strokes.
You know, I've worked at other agencies,
some where I've managed a ton of accounts,
some mid-sized and then some bigger ones,
where I am down to square one client only,
but I've never been in any transition
from one to another.
So, I think that's a--
- What's your concern in that transition?
- [Stephen] I don't know.
Should I be concerned?
- Well that's what's really
good about this question.
I think it's a good theoretical question,
and I think it's less scary in real life,
which is why I ask that,
and which is why I'm glad
the way you answered.
I think you're worried
about the boogie man.
You know what I mean?
I think you're trying to be thoughtful,
which is amazing.
It's what you want from
leaders to begin with.
So that's a good tell,
but I think, you know, hey Carl,
you're on seven accounts,
now you're on four.
- [Stephen] And we're
just gonna cut this back?
- Yeah.
Get 'em.
- [Stephen] Yeah.
- Some people might get,
like are you worried
about the internal part?
Like the actual employees
that work for you?
Like making that transition?
- [Stephen] Sure, I
mean it could be, yeah.
'Cause it's a completely
different mindset.
- Yeah I think it's a boogie man thing.
Really, I do.
Like, it's a different mindset
that either that person
can do or can't do.
- [Stephen] Mhmm.
- You're probably, we're
not gonna know if they can
or can't, you know?
A lot of these, you know what I mean?
I think people prep for
things a lot of times
that there was no preparation needed for.
- [Stephen] Gotcha.
- Think about how much
you psyche yourself out
for the first time you
were gonna kiss somebody.
Years for something, years.
Like, you know, some of these
things are just overthought.
It's casting too.
Carol's gonna transition beautifully.
Rick, not so much.
- [Stephen] Rick.
- Yeah, Rick.
You know what I mean?
- [Stephen] Yeah.
- I think for you on the
financial side it's easy,
'cause you're just allocating.
- [Stephen] Mhmm.
- And then it's just, this
is why culture matters.
- [Stephen] Right.
- Dude, this is why
culture fucking matters.
If you do part one, anything
that's scary about part two
the culture eats up and fixes.
Carol, who's struggling
from going from four to one,
'cause she's bored is gonna
feel safe to talk about it.
Instead of looking for
another job to get challenged.
This place got too big,
let me go somewhere
where I can get that high of 10 accounts.
- [Stephen] Mhmm.
- See where I'm going?
- [Stephen] Yeah.
- Culture.
Culture's like oxygen.
People think it's like a
department, people think, you know?
It's not like finance.
It's fucking a living and breathing thing.
It is the operating system.
It is not one of the apps.
Finance is an app.
Creative is an app.
Strategy is an app.
Culture's the fucking operating system.
- [Bryan B.] That's a good
analogy, really good analogy.
- It's probably the
proudest thing I'm up to.
It's one of the most proud--
I'm so proud that what I'm
putting into the business
ecosystem around this subject matter,
'cause I'm an alpha guy.
It's not like, you know,
I'm not like, you know,
an 88 year old grandma
saying culture, you know.
Like I'm alpha, but this is real,
and I'm glad that it's,
like, starting to pick up
a little momentum.
It's gonna really pay out.
So that's what I think.
- [Stephen] I think the
reason I was asking that,
it was because I've been
in both of those roles,
just the depth of analysis
and quality of work
that you're expected to--
- But the client is the judge and the jury
of the quality of the work.
- [Stephen] Right.
- Which is a variable.
- [Stephen] Bigger client,
higher expectations.
- Potentially.
- [Stephen] Gotcha.
- It's casting.
The bigger client just might
have gone to the same college
as you and likes you and has
decided your work's better.
(laughing)
Play in real life.
- [Stephen] Okay.
- That's what I do, got it?
Potentially.
The client is the judge and the jury,
but they're a human, like a referee.
All I need to know about
referees is he's a human being.
It's making a subjective call
based on his knowledge
of what past interference
is or isn't.
- [Stephen] Perfect.
- You understand?
- [Stephen] Yep.
- It's an ideology that you hope
he doesn't write every time.
He can't.
What angle does, these
guys are going so fast.
One of my biggest things
with referees is they need
to get into better shape.
- Obviously.
- No, but, you know,
obviously I'm making fun joke,
but it's fucking hard out.
I mean, I'm very weird with refs.
I barely every upset with referees
'cause I'm like, it's fucking hard.
You know how fast these motherfuckers are?
- It's really fast.
- No matter how smart
he is about positioning
and he can have film for days,
to be on the 36 yard line
and this hash, these fuckers are moving,
and so what?
You're mad at them 'cause
you watched it a minute later
in super, triple slow?
Do you know fast this shit is?
So, the same way I think about refereeing
is the same way I think about clients.
It's casting.
I have plenty of small
clients that are way tougher
than big clients.
(laughing)
There's plenty of people
paying me $11 million
that are passive as fuck
and people pay me $48 and pissed as shit.
(laughing)
- [Bryan B.] Had that.
- Got it?
- [Taylor] Oh yeah (laughs)
(group chattering)
- The key for your business is learning
when to fire a client.
Which is foreign as fuck.
- [Doug] Gotta switch when you're young.
- Of course, especially when--
And by the way, when you're young
and don't have the
leverage, you don't fire.
Kids always ask me,
"Gary, when do I fire?"
I'm like, "Can you afford it?"
"No."
Then you don't fire.
(laughing)
You fire when you can afford it, you know?
- [Bryan N.] Makes sense.
- Things are great and--
You should fire clients that
are bad to your employees
to keep up the culture.
It's the operating system.
Yes, but if you fire them
and go out of business
there is no operating system.
(laughing)
You know?
- [Taylor] Great, so one thing I was
really curious about, is
as we are a young agency
and starting to build ourselves up,
kinda finding the line
between building up,
and this might tie into
the personal branding thing
we're gonna have,
but the line between putting
our work and our time
into building our brand,
and then how do you balance that with
the work that is driving revenue?
Like your client work, and--
- You have to do both.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- It's hard in the beginning,
but the answer is both.
The client is subjective.
So you gotta be thoughtful
that you're not deciding
how much time and effort you
have to put into the work.
You can make a video, I mean,
look, you're a creative.
You know this.
You can make something
that takes you 13 minutes
that they think is the
most remarkable thing
they've ever seen
and you can do something
that's your life's work
and then you walk in and they're like,
this is a piece of shit.
You're in the complete subjective game.
So you have to use the advantages of that
while recognizing the disadvantages of it.
Understand?
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Are you a perfectionist
because you're insecure
and you spend two more
hours editing something
because of your own ideological
nature of perfection
which could have been used
to work on your brand,
or are you not?
Got it?
- [Taylor] Yep.
- You know, a lot of creatives
don't like to hear speed
and output and quantity matters,
and I'm sure it's a
friction on my own team.
I'm looking at D, like, it's no,
like, when people, D, what,
four months now for you, five?
Like, when you first come
in, it's like, look, like,
I have a--
I'm so respectful.
I think creative is the
variable of success.
So it's really funny because
I don't look the part
of like the champion of a creative,
but it really is what I believe,
and it's what I am.
I also equally believe
in output and speed.
There's such a practical part to me.
It's no different than what I just said.
I'm saying the same things
over and over, both.
Like, if you break
everything down, it's both.
It's always both.
The answer's both.
(laughing)
It's why we have a
problem in this country.
People think it's left or right.
The answer's both.
I can't believe how much
our country now believes
it's one or the other.
It's nuances of both.
- [Stephen] Good deal.
- The good nuances.
So anyways, the answer's both.
- [Taylor] Mhmm.
(laughing)
Okay.
So when it comes to like, I mean--
- If you're not building brand,
you're not creating funnels
that give you new business,
in a way that's passive.
If you're not delivering
on the quality of work,
you're not retaining.
It's like eating in the old days,
you have to hunt and farm.
The answer's both.
So like, what does that mean?
More hours or hire more people.
Its' not super complicated.
Or, the one that, 'cause
those are tough, both,
being efficient with your actual time.
When people come in here,
do you know how many of
my employees are like,
"I need somebody on this account."
I'm like, "I'm not giving you
somebody on that account."
And they're mad, they're like,
"You fucking tried to burn me out."
I'm like, "No, you're on fucking
Reddit for an hour a day."
- [Taylor] Yep, I guess that's me.
- Yep, good.
- [Carrie] Me?
- Yep.
- [Carrie] All right, cool.
He's gonna ask you the big question.
- Okay, so ask the even bigger question.
(laughing)
- [Carrie] I have two questions for you.
One is business advice
and the other one is,
selfishly, some life advice.
- Let's go.
- [Carrie] So, the first one being,
our business has been building
the past three years are new,
and very successfully we've reached--
and what I feel from my observation,
where the brand is, is it's
very personally branded,
and we discuss this all the time,
about at some point VaynerMedia was Gary,
and how do we remove human--
- 98% of the people that
work here still think
that's our biggest problem.
- [Carrie] Right, right.
- So let's talk about that for a couple--
The reason I answered you that way,
98% of the people here feel
that I'm too far ahead--
Most people don't care about it,
but the people that are
trying to help this company,
like my direct reports
and most of the feed,
and we had a new Head of Com.
We're hiring a new Head of Comms.
I interviewed a lot of people.
It was the number one thing
they wanted to talk about.
"Gary, so excited if I
get this opportunity.
"I'm so excited, to like, you know,
"build up the brand of
Vayner so it's not just..."
Now, there's things that
come along with that.
If he hates it too much
or loves it too much,
both are a problem.
(group chattering in agreement)
Got it?
So I don't know.
The answer is you're fine in theory.
More than you can imagine.
- [Carrie] Okay.
- But we're at the
vulnerability of him as a human,
and if he hates it too much,
it's stressful, he doesn't
want somebody to take a selfie,
or like clients call him
instead of the people you build around,
or if he likes it too much
and it becomes a caricature of himself
and he gets high on his own supply.
- [Stephen] I get real high.
- So that's the answer to that question.
- [Carrie] So what we're
trying to do, mistakenly,
is we think it's a logical
problem that we need to resolve,
as he's the bottleneck of the company,
but in actual fact it's
an emotional problem.
Where if he's not emotional about it,
he is who is is,
and the The One Percent is well, 1%.
- [Linh] Because I'm the brand.
People want me, people
want my strategy overside.
"Did Linh approve this?"
- So, that's where you're
making an operational mistake.
So, one thing I did not make
an operational mistake about
is nobody gets me,
and never was it promised.
Now, if you, if Pepsi
comes along and says,
"Well, we'd like you
for these three, like,
"we want you for, like."
It's all negotiable,
but it was never in play.
- [Linh] Right,
and you made that clear
from the beginning,
so I don't become the bottleneck.
- The end.
- [Linh] And they don't get pissed.
- Right, they made a decision.
I told them right to their face,
you do not get me.
I do not work on any account.
I am not here.
I'm in the bat phone business.
That better be bat phone shit,
like the Joker's fucking choking someone.
(laughing)
Not, there's a puddle
in the street Batman,
you know what I mean?
I'm in the Batman business,
but I was, where does this shit come from?
(laughing)
Where does this shit come from?
Ah, man.
- [Bryan N.] Batman,
Robin, it's coming on.
- I like communicating in that way
'cause it makes it obvious.
Even though it's funny and ridiculous,
it's very clear of what I'm telling you.
You wanna call me because your business
is in real trouble or
like, you're super upset
with the people managing your business.
We can have that convo,
but I'm not gonna fucking
review that tweet.
(Bryan N. Laughs)
- [Carrie] Okay, so,
- Expectations up front.
Which takes humility
from the person.
The thing that most
people are unable to see
about me until they really get closer
is the humility part that comes
along with the confidence,
you know?
Takes humility of the personal brand.
- [Carrie] So my second
question, less of a question,
but I want to hear your thoughts,
when I tell you about this,
and I highly respect
everyone who doesn't get us
and is vulnerable enough to talk
about themselves and their position
because I'm feeling very nervous.
- Go ahead.
- [Carrie] I wanna kinda set
the tone with the end in mind.
- Please.
- [Carrie] We are super
happy living with my parents.
They're the best people in the world,
and it took us a long time to get there.
- [Linh] We took your advice--
- [Carrie] But here's what happened.
- Wow, that makes me
super happy.
- [Carrie] Phase one,
we were getting serious
in our relationships,
and we decided to buy a house,
and we talked a lot about the
unconventional success metric
of what you do a mortgage
and sell myself to death.
- Yep.
(laughing)
I'm telling you.
I mean it, I mean it.
Indian culture, Russian
culture, it's the same shit.
Obviously there's a couple that outlie,
but like stuff to prove you won
is how humans are wired.
Go ahead.
- [Carrie] So, we bought a house.
If you see our stock account,
I'm going to refer back to data,
that was the time when
the first growth happened
in the company
because there was lot of pressure,
and there was a deadline.
- Interesting.
- [Linh] I do well under pressure.
- I understand.
- [Carrie] Cool, so--
- Maybe.
- [Carrie] The problem with this house was
we couldn't use the garage.
- We need to talk about that.
- [Carrie] And so, one day,
when we had to park on the street,
we parked a little bit further down
and two houses down
it's a massive mansion.
This is about nine months later.
There was an open house,
and we walk in the house,
and he was like, "We
should buy this house."
and I'm like--
- You buy a, I wanna make
sure I'm following this.
You buy a house, two houses
over, nine months earlier.
- [Linh] Yep, the first house.
- Understood, yep.
You, at that same time,
are starting the business,
and it's starting to work.
- [Carrie] Mhmm.
- [Linh] And starting to work.
- I understand, it's starting to work.
Like good things are
happening in the business.
You're starting to see
the early indications
of something good is happening.
So, what you do with
those early indications
is decide that you should
buy the bigger house.
- [Linh] Correct.
- By the way, that makes
a ton of sense to me.
Keep going.
- [Carrie] Okay, and so, he's the dreamer.
I'm the believer.
I'm like, this house is three times
of what our current house is.
If you think we can do it,
let's do it.
We signed the papers.
So two weeks later, I
had to buy this house.
In the meantime, the
same agent sold our house
and they're like, this is so good,
and look at our swipe account
and that was our second
huge spike in growth
and sustained growth, if I may add.
So, it's not just like that.
- [Linh] Yeah, literally from--
- That might've had nothing
to do with the houses,
by the way.
That might've been--
- [Linh] I bought the house
not even being able to afford it.
I understand,
but the growth might've not happened
because you're under pressure.
It might've been because you are right
about the thesis of what you were doing.
- [Carrie] I want to test that now
because--
- Good.
- [Carrie] Now that we're
so happy and comfortable
and--
- You wanna make yourself
more uncomfortable.
- [Carrie] This thing has
emotionally wrecked us.
- If you play a game,
let me say one thing,
and I don't know if
this where you're going,
but I'm just gonna jump in
because I like to do that.
(laughing)
If you're gonna play a game of like
every time we put
ourselves in macro-pressure
that we are this united front,
and we emotionally and
financially and strategically
we have big spikes of growth,
you're gonna pick wrong one day.
- [Carrie] I don't want that to happen.
- So, don't make that your thesis.
- [Carrie] For sure and I--
- Figure out to create
pressure in a different way
than it isn't financially--
- [Carrie] Yeah, so now we
don't have financial pressure
because we've--
- I understand, you've
grown into being able
to afford it easier.
I get it.
- [Carrie] We've grown to--
- I understand.
- [Carrie] really just
enjoying what we do.
- Okay.
- [Carrie] But now, our business
growth isn't as exciting,
if that makes sense.
- Of course it makes sense,
but that might not have anything
to do with the pressure.
I'm worried that you're
scrapping at something
that might've been
serendipitous, not the engine of.
It may also not be as exciting
because the maturity of what you're doing
is now doing much of the same.
Whereas before, it was
learning or finding,
doing, they're maybe a lot of reasons
that it's not as exciting,
unless you're just
masochists of financial,
and I'm not joking, maybe?
I can't, I don't know you well enough,
but it's highly unlikely
that that's the case,
but wait a minute, you
live with your parents?
- [Carrie] Yeah, we do.
- You moved them into your house you mean?
- [Linh] No, we moved back in with them--
- So, you sold that big house?
- [Linh] We still have it.
It's the--
- [Carrie] What we've
done is we've turned it
into a business of trade,
so it's worked out really perfectly.
- I see, that's cool.
- [Linh] We run events there.
- I understand.
- [Carrie] Yeah, so that's really exciting
on that end.
Maybe that's a really great segue--
- Maybe, there's also another thing
and I'll let him segue,
but another thing for you to debate,
maybe you should start a new business.
That's what I do.
- [Carrie] Yup.
- I just keep starting new businesses
and some will fail and some won't,
but in the net, I don't give a fuck
'cause I'm happy.
Starting a new business
for me makes me happy.
It's make me happy.
I'm not really worried about,
like I love when everybody,
you know everybody around,
straight men and women
are like (groaning),
I'm like, I wanna be happy.
I'm like, you can quit Vayner
and start your own company
if you wanna be safe.
(laughing)
- [Carrie] Yeah, I think that brings
a lot of closure for me
'cause no way do I want to test us
with financial pressure again.
I just knew that wasn't the right way.
- You can pressure yourself
and challenge yourself,
without it being the financial part.
It can be the intellectual part.
One of the reasons I
love to start businesses
is to see how right I am about something.
Because I love when people are like,
"Oh, I thought of Uber before Uber."
I'm like, that's great, Johnny.
What does that mean?
(laughing)
I love people talking about shit.
"Oh, I knew Snap stock was gonna go,"
What does that even mean?
I'm in the business of putting my mouth,
my money where my mouth is.
Maybe that's what you're looking for.
- [Carrie] Yeah.
- Do you know what I mean?
- [Carrie] There are
two takeaways from that,
which is one, owner bribes
going to go into it--
- Just because you like concentrating,
that's amazing.
That's phenomenal.
I think it's a great thesis.
I think it's an incredible thesis
that you should focus on
something and see it home.
How 'bout the fact that I got D's and F's
for that same macro-rational?
Or you could be me,
which is you love throwing up 47 plates
and you're comfortable if 16 collapse
because you like 31 plates more than one.
- [Carrie] Yup, and I love the takeaway
of challenging us intellectually.
- 100%
- [Carrie] Yeah,
'cause at the moment, it's
always been financial--
- That's right,
honestly, you just made me so happy.
If you can get into
legacy,
curiosity,
process
over bank account,
I don't think I've ever really known
how much money I've had, ever.
I have no clue right now.
- [Carrie] Yeah.
Enough to be dangerous to make sure it's
enough to not be dead,
but like, when your process
is the game,
you're in a much better place.
- [Carrie] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Linh] So we work with niche
health and fitness partners--
- I heard.
- [Linh] The big thing that I teach them
and we teach them as a
company is to build tribes,
to build 1,000 raving fans
around that one key area--
- I understand
'cause the monetization against that
versus 100,000 that don't give a fuck
means nothing.
- [Linh] Correct,
and so, as I go deeper,
I'm starting to realize
they can't monetize coaching
because very few people
pay for high-end coaching.
Like you said before,
people pay for tangibility.
People don't pay for improvement--
- Yeah and it often times,
where it really becomes
an interesting debate for a lot of people,
depending on how they're wired,
for example, I can get a
lot of money for coaching.
I don't want to.
So, there's two groups.
Ones that can't and there's
ones that subconsciously,
actually don't want to
because an enormous percentage
of people that pay for coaching,
are paying for the feeling
that they're fixing something,
versus actually trying to fix it.
One of the reasons I really struggle
with a lot of people I know
is they're bottom feeding on people,
and so, you gotta figure out which group.
It's an important question for you,
when you meet somebody.
You're like, hey, you can do this.
It's either that they can't fill the pipe
with valuable enough content
or actually, they'd be more
like me, which is interesting,
which is they just don't
feel good about it.
It's an important part.
Whereas, I'm thrilled to
sell a hoodie or a sneaker
or a glass of wine.
- [Linh] Because coaching's so intangible,
and most people don't rise and don't get--
- It's also very important
to analyze your customer.
Coaching's very tough
when you know the person's
looking for a quick fix.
- [Linh] Yeah, and the majority are.
- 100,000%.
- [Linh] And that's the reality.
- The end, and then what it does
is takes people out of their truth
because there are a wise
to coaching business.
- [Linh] Correct.
So, we're kinda in a
very ambiguous business
because we have these experts
who are coaching clients to end result.
My job as their tribe
leader is figuring out how
to help them build their
tribes and connect the dots
to help them actually deliver
their coaching for free,
build that tribe
and then monetize on
product, services, ecommerce,
supplements, meal-prep, recurring stuff.
So, I've got two questions for you,
in order for us to do that,
I need to get myself
into the software space
to allow them a platform
to build their tribe.
- 'Kay.
- [Linh] That's what I'm starting to feel.
The 200 coaches that we have,
if they can all have one
white-labeled software
that they use to deliver to their tribe,
that can then open up the door
for them to segue in affiliate products,
meal-prep, supplements--
- I understand.
- [Linh] that kind of stuff.
So right now, we've kind
of got two empty gaps.
The first empty gap
is, if you were us now,
we had 200 clients, we had
a $3,000,000 revenue, sales,
how do you begin to enter
into software and tech,
knowing that that's the future of fitness
and that will help your clients grow
and they need software and tech,
and then the second question is
how do you form strategic partnerships
with other product services,
for example, supplement companies,
meal-prep companies, apparel.
So that you bring under one
bigger and broader brand
and use the software
where they build a tribe,
so that they don't make so
much money on the coaching,
but everything else is
so much so, leading with,
cool, you're prescription
is to buy this meal-plan.
If--
- I understand.
You either build a tech
or you rent the tech
or you buy the tech.
The end.
- [Linh] That's what I tend to as well.
- I think everyone's different, you know.
You wanna feel more financial pressure,
take a lot of the
$3,000,000 revenue business
and deploy it against buying something
from maybe a company that thought
they were building a
consumer tech platform,
but they didn't realize
how fuckin' hard that was
and they failed and
they've run out of money
and you can scoop up the tech.
The first thing you probably have to do
is bring somebody that
looks like these two
directly in their life as a partner.
Or somebody who actually gives a fuck.
The biggest mistake that people make
when they go into the tech business
is they try to outsource the CTO
and it's different than where he is going.
I mean if you're gonna
be in the tech business,
and in essence, you're
gonna now start selling
a SAS product to all these individuals,
you better fucking have
somebody who gives a fuck
for the next eight years at your hip,
and a lot of times,
it's an entrepreneur who
knows nothing about it
and they think they're gonna be clever
and have somebody build this SAS product
in fucking Poland and then what happens
when there's a fucking update?
And what happens when something break,
like, they fuck this up all the time.
What I would do, I'd probably
give up 5% of the company
and hire a CTO and have
her or him build it
or analyze the situation and say,
"Actually we don't need to build it.
"These three series of
products in the marketplace,
"We add in one layer on top of it,
"We use their APIs and
we've got a product."
- Financial analyzing (laughs).
- And see what's really
interesting about this, right,
so what's interesting is, and
these people actually do it,
like what, and this is actually
just an insight for all of you,
what's interesting about me
and probably what's manifested with me
is I'm dangerous enough to
be able to give that answer,
where people that actually know are like,
fuck that's a good answer, right?
That's something that just
good for everybody to learn.
Back to all the plates,
I think something that
people don't understand
is how important it is
to be dangerous enough,
and you better be dangerous
enough in technology
and communication because
that's where our world's going
until all of us die.
Those two things are here.
You better be dangerous
enough in understanding tech
and you better be dangerous
enough in understanding
how to communicate, which
currently is social media.
That's probably a much bigger
factor in who I am right now
than maybe even I articulate enough.
I'm glad I just did that
because that really fuckin' matters
'cause you do have to
market your business,
even if you're B2B
and you should know how
to do LinkedIn marketing
because it'll change your businesses.
You go in as a SAS, you
can't rent that shit.
- [Linh] Has to be part of me.
- Has to be part of you.
So, hey listen, one of the weird,
I think the mistake a lot of people
would make four years ago
is you're gonna learn how to code.
Everybody thought that was
the unlocked, you know?
It's a commodity.
Every kid, like, I couldn't get,
I was so pumped five years ago
when everyone was sending
their kid to learn how to code.
I'm like, this is going to be awesome.
Coding is going to be like plumbing.
I'm gonna be paying fucking
$26,000 a year for it.
Everyone's like, "You're
gonna make $250,000."
I'm like, do people understand
basic human supply and demand?
(laughing)
If everybody learns how to code,
the reason all those kids
that actually were nerds
and learned how to code
and popped out in 2003,
'04, '05, '06 mattered is
'cause that's when it was coming
and nobody had the skill
and so that's why they won.
Every fuckin', if every eight year-old
learns how to fuckin' code, right?
- [Linh] Yeah, Gary, just on that thought,
where would you find a CTO?
Like where am I looking at?
- You know, look bro, honestly,
this is why I love this shit.
You should talk to these two.
They probably know people.
There's a lot of ways to go about this.
You can just, either talk
to people like Mark or,
these people probably know,
I mean your in Australia.
They may not know.
There's things to talk about here.
You can decide to go remote.
You can be like me
and you want all the
(foreign language) here.
Whatever you do, but it's
not as hard as you think.
One thing that I've always
liked to do in the beginning
is you look at shit in
the world that you like
and you literally do four hours of Google
to find people that built it.
You find that it's an
agency that built it here
and you reach, and you
look on the agency site,
and you literally see Head
of Product, Karen Thompson,
and inevitably, her
Twitter is linked to it
and you just DM her and
say, "Karen Thompson,
"your fuckin' app that
you built for Honeybee
"was really rad and a great product.
"I'm lookin' to hire a CTO."
And she's like, "As a matter of fact,
"our head of development over here
"just said to me yesterday
that I want a new job."
I mean, like, you work.
- [Linh] Yeah, awesome.
Onto the second question,
the strategic partnerships
with the consumer product companies--
- You reach out to them.
Everyone of them's interested.
You email info@.
- [Linh] Would you
start your own consumer,
would you start your own brand?
- Depends on what you
think you're good at.
You know, if you think you're good
at the toll booth business,
you build a toll booth.
If you think you're good
at the highway business,
you build a highway.
That's what the two things are.
If you wanna sit in the middle,
and somebody's building a meal-plan,
and you're sitting in the middle,
and there's influencers,
and you sit in the
middle and you arbitrage,
that's what you do.
You think you, that's the toll booth.
If you think you're good
enough to fuckin' make
the meal plan, that's the highway.
Biggest companies in the world right now
were the toll booths of the internet.
Amazon, Apple, this is
why Mark loves Blockchain.
That eliminates the toll booths.
Got it?
That's why I like personal brands
and why I wrote "Crush It" in--
the pedestal that my book,
"Crush It" is gonna be put on
in 30 years is remarkably
exciting for me personally
because what, at scale,
what Blockchain does
is justifies the behavior
of people building
personal brand because it's the only thing
going to be left is the thing
and the audience on the other side.
There will be many technologies built on,
like the thesis, and I don't
know how it will evolve
and I'm not dangerous enough, just yet,
to fully have even great thesis on this,
but my lightweight thesis on this,
and it's super macro.
I'm very confident, which is,
there's the person and the audience,
and in a lot of ways that's
what the internet did,
but then people layered on top of it,
which led to the next innovation.
That's all.
The internet's gonna
feel like the networks.
- [Doug] Cool.
- Cool.
- So, just two questions.
This kinda goes into, actually
like you were just saying,
like removing certain things.
So, originally, I built
an app for a sports agent
who wanted to put herself out of business.
So, basically it was
an app that acts like--
- It's funny, that's the same
agenda I had for VaynerSports.
Put everybody out of business.
(laughing)
Go ahead.
- And this one's like basically,
it's direct to the player
can sign their contract
with the brand, and then--
- So smart.
Oh, brand, from a marketing standpoint.
Understood.
- And then he goes into escrow
and then when they either do--
- Yep, got it, I understand.
- So, done this, going
through it, copyright it,
done stuff with ESPN.
Got to be with AJ for VaynerSports,
interview him.
- That's awesome.
- But the thing was, I
can do things like that.
I can be in ESPN, I can do this.
Now, it goes into who we
sometimes represent, right?
So, we have one of the
clients, it's Lil Skies,
and so he's on tour, and so like, the guy,
the partner I have, he
has his own business,
but he's a videographer.
So, he does everything with him.
So, he did a documentary about
him, his family, everything,
but there's one thing that I,
when we're trying to get bigger coverage
with bigger, like
complex, things like that,
it seems like it's moving targets.
We can get smaller outlets,
but there's always seems
to the decision maker,
it's not the editor,
it's always moving
when we're trying to distribute
that kind of content.
What we do is micro-docs for those,
for those influencers.
- Well it's because,
it's because they have the leverage.
- Yeah.
- It's a moving target
because it's a highly political decision.
You want free distribution potentially,
and attention is the asset.
If Complex, or as we
continue to build ONE37pm,
if you're gonna hit me up and be like,
"Yo! We made this awesome",
and Skies fuckin' on
it right now, matters.
- Exactly.
- And I'm gonna have to say to myself,
like, but I don't wanna,
the content's a commodity.
- Mhmm.
- I'm like, fuck it,
let's just go make our own
Tee Grizzley documentary.
Like, 'cause we've got the audience.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right?
And so, and content is the variable
and the most important thing,
but the supply of content is remarkable.
There's 877 SoundCloud rapper
documentaries being made
right now.
- Exactly.
- Because everybody wants to be DRock,
and like there's a lot going on, right?
So like, that's why it's,
that's why that's happening
because they're trying to figure out,
they'd rather do it themselves.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah.
- And they're gonna continue
to go down that route.
Everything's gonna be fully integrated.
People are gonna make and
distribute themselves.
- Yeah.
Which brings up, okay, so--
- You see where I'm going?
- That, so--
- You can still catch some stuff
because the decision maker's just like,
"Fuck, I fuck with Lil Skies.
"This was fresh."
But they don't wanna pay money for it.
- Or they don't wanna share the revenue
when they get a sponsored
to layer on top of it.
This is why I'm building it this way.
- Yeah.
- Think about what I'm doing.
VaynerMedia has the
relationship with the brand.
The publishing company is
the distribution, right?
The media part of VaynerMedia
is enhanced distribution.
You see what I'm doing?
- Yeah.
- I don't want to be at
the mercy of anybody.
- That makes sense,
and so with this business model,
the thing that we're using is almost,
which is kinda unique when
we're doing these mini-docs,
what we're trying to do
is actually just either
give the rights or something
to whatever platform,
but use that as leverage for
other, getting other clients.
So we're not actually looking to--
- Okay, so when you say other clients,
you're charging the artist?
- Um, well actually a lot of them,
it depends on which artist.
- Makes sense.
- So if they're--
- Drake not so much.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- Skies two years ago, maybe.
- Exactly, so when Skies,
the videographer,
we actually are all from the same town,
like, from years ago.
So, he documented Skies
since he was seven,
all the way up.
- That's amazing.
- And his father almost
died when he was like 14.
The whole reason Skies started rapping was
his father got in a horrible accident,
third degree burns everywhere,
couldn't speak for awhile,
and he rapped, but he taught
his kid and everything
and that's actually how Skies grow.
- That's insane.
- So he has the whole doc--
- I didn't know that.
- He has all of these stories.
- Well that sounds like a
unique piece of content,
and that I would be more careful with.
- Mhmm.
I wonder, okay.
- That sounds, you know,
and this is why content is the variable.
- Yeah.
- Right,
You know like, so as
you added more content
that seems unique.
If you got footage of that shit--
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, that's unique to me.
I think that I wouldn't like,
I would be more thoughtful about.
That to me I think you
need to try to reach out to
Hulu and Amazon and Netflix,
try to really go for the jugular.
- Yeah.
- Not even, like I think,
to your point, lower places.
I don't even think you
play in the Complex, Vice,
like hype-y, I think you fucking jugular,
if you've got that footage.
- 'Cause the footage is the value.
- Yeah and it's, he has all the footage
when he was recovering--
- It's funny, it's making
me think about something
that I don't think people understand,
literally the most valuable asset
that I put in a trust for my kids
is all the IP footage of
everything I'm recording.
(everybody agreeing)
Yeah, it's wild right?
'Cause it had no value,
so the value on it when I put
it in the trust is like $100,000, so--
- [Bryan B.] State tax and
everything is gonna be minimal.
- My intuition is if you actually project
the potential of VR 50 years from today,
somebody might, you could
have unlimited people
paying $19.99 to sit
in that seat right now
and think they're in this room.
I always use the analogy of,
would I today pay, and
how much would I pay
to sit in the room of a
meeting between Bill Gates
and Steve Jobs in 1984?
For me, the way I learn a lot,
'cause I'm good at contextual history,
so I'd pay the five Gs,
'cause I could afford it,
and because I know if I
sat there and listened
they would say something
that I could contextualize
into 2019 that would help me.
- It's good.
- Interesting right?
- I like it.
- This is the last question.
It was dealing with all the
things we were talking about,
CTO and all the things.
What I've developed is basically,
it's called being a full
SAG Brand Developer.
- Yeah I understand.
- Basically, to make sure
I've been copywriting that,
and what I'm focusing on,
I have severe dyslexia
and I think kids need to
learn how to basically
learn these skills because it's just not,
I was terrible at school.
You can use it, it just doesn't
work the same way with that.
So, I'm basically putting
this together as a program
and I don't know--
- A curriculum?
- Yeah and I don't know if
it's, should it be feasible
where I should even care about
a revenue stream or do that,
or just worry about the
program and try to teach it
to as many the kids as possible.
- Well, that's a personal question, right?
I think that, look, all of
us have different levels
of what they want to do selfishly
and what you want to do selflessly, right?
And so I never judged that.
I think that's circumstantial, right?
I chose the route, maybe
'cause I had options,
'cause I knew how to build
businesses otherwise,
to not monetize my audience,
but I don't judge that.
I don't judge that,
and I don't think anybody should live
to anybody else's standard.
Maybe you start charging
at first, it hits pay dirt,
you did well and you're like,
fuck, I've done well now
and this clearly is
working, let me make it free
for everybody in the world.
Maybe you start it, maybe
you go more my route,
you make it free, that
builds up equity in itself
and it lets you monetize in other places
where you get to speak for,
like there's a lot of ways to do this
and I don't think there's a right way.
There's only a right way for you.
I hate when people try
to impose their way.
You know, and I'm very passionate,
but I'm not trying to impose my way,
'cause it's fucking free,
I'm trying to use it as a context point
and you can do whatever you want with it.
- Mhmm, makes sense.
- You know, it's something
I'm trying to clarify more,
of like, I don't think I'm right.
I think I'm right for me.
It's a data point and your
ability to synthesize that
and understand your own
nuances is the key, you know?
- Thank you.
- Who's right, Tony Robbins or Oprah?
They're different.
Oprah had the luxury of TV deal
to not charge her audience,
but that's what she did after
because that's, you know?
I don't know.
I don't like to, I don't
want to have a mastermind.
I don't want to have a, I don't,
but I don't mind selling you sneakers,
'cause my big thing there is,
if you're wearing sneakers anyway,
you know, so for me it's comfortable.
I want to give away my content,
and I do look at people
that sell their content
more cynically I do, but that's okay.
It doesn't mean I'm right,
and cynicism is actually wrong.
It's not for me.
You do you, you can do either,
and they both can work.
You can hold your breath,
build equity on giving it away for free
and then do something on the other side
for yourself.
It's a long game,
or you can charge from the beginning,
'cause you need it right
now and that's fine too.
There's too much judgment
in the system right now
on one or the other, you know?
Just, that, we've gone
on full judgment tilt.
Do whatever the fuck you wanna do.
- And that's why I built an
agency to work with the clients
because I can give it away--
- I got it.
I got it bro.
I wanted to buy brands one day
when the economy collapsed.
That's why I built an agency.
Like I shouldn't be in client services,
but I have a strategy.
The economy has decided not to collapse.
(laughing)
Still sittin' here, but,
you know like, you know,
but know the machine is like way greater.
Now, I can really swallow Reebok,
let alone fuckin', you know?
In some ways, what I perceived as like,
fuck, why won't this thing fuckin' clap?
Well, my own thesis on myself, right?
The longer it's gone,
the more leverage I have.
I used to think that it
was gonna fold Vayner
and take 20% of the team
and work on Aquafina.
Now, I won't have to do that.
Now, somebody else is
gonna run Vayner, you know?
- Yeah, so, I'm having
a, what I'm calling it,
maybe an identity deal,
uh, problem.
So, I've got my company's Blind
Zebra, you get that, right?
- Yes, I get it.
- Thank you,
and I'm doing sales training,
sales coaching, for myself in Indy,
for 22 years.
I've intentionally wanted
to be an independent,
just me, single shingle, lifestyle biz,
shut it down, done.
- Good for you.
- Two years ago, I'm like, you know what?
There's no reason not to skip this.
- Good for you too.
By the way, I love that story.
I think that's one thing
that I wish more people understood.
You can change your mind.
- Yeah and especially I'm
the only guy at the table
with readers I think,
- I get it.
- so those are the old days.
- So, I've got, here are the brands
and I wanna get your opinion on
if I handed 'em to you,
what's the first two
things you think about?
Sales training, sales coaching,
keynote speaking,
my wife and I are flying
into San Francisco
to launch a wine biz.
I have business ADD.
We'll meet with John Wilkinson
from the Bin to Bottle--
- Amazing.
- A lot of the same guys.
It's a sports oriented in a can
for sports people.
- Love.
- Blind Zebra is gonna be in for
referee calls.
- Love it.
- That one's gonna be
called a legal substitution,
(laughing)
there we go.
- I'm in for a case.
Can't wait.
- Okay, you're in.
We're doing, in the fall
launch, I think a Hustle Fest
'cause it turned into my full, real hustle
and a lot of guys in Indy,
Gary Brackett, Pat McAfee,
done the same thing.
Gonna rent out a place, do that.
That's Hustle Fest,
and I've been doin'
podcasting for 14 years.
I've got 650 episodes and sales.
It's called the Advanced Selling Podcast.
I've got a partner in that business.
Got a decent LinkedIn tribe.
We've got about 11,000 people in a group
and then we've got about
5,000 people on an email list,
and I personally went
heavy in LinkedIn early on
and I've got about 11,000
LinkedIn connections.
That's my big, just my own
personal, individual deal.
So, that's the lay of the land.
Now, I'm trying to figure out,
okay, what--
- Well, what would you like to happen?
So, if I said to you that, you know,
just in business you'd
like to do more revenue.
So, if I just said--
- They're all separate.
Yeah, I get separate engines for each one.
So, the sales training
thing will be scaled.
So, I've got this public
program called Training Camp.
Everything's around
football with the brand.
So, I've got Training Camp in Indy,
and so I want we have
Training Camp in Chicago,
Training Camp in Columbus,
Ohio, Training Camp in New York.
- How are you going to do that?
- Certified coaches, like me
and I've got the contents already built.
I just need to go out
and then we're gonna feed leads to them.
It's gonna be the
stickiness that well have--
- Franchise?
- I don't think it's gonna be a franchise
that complicates
something similar to that.
- Yep.
- Speaking, I just need
an agency to rep me.
I just don't do anything
to promote myself.
- There's no agency
that wants a rep anybody
who hasn't created the
leverage for themselves first.
- Right.
- Doesn't exist.
- Is a podcast with
150,000 downloads a month
enough leverage or not?
Gotta be bigger.
- No, it's not that.
- What is it?
- It's you need to be speaking.
- Oh,
I am.
- Good.
- I'm gonna do something.
- Do more.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And film the shit out
of it and put it out.
Got it?
- Yup, yup.
The wine business is a
distribution business.
We've got I think 80 colleges
that are opening up alcohol sales.
You got NFL, NHL, Major League Baseball
and you go to a tailgate or,
there's no, want sports specific wine
and it's in a can, so it's single use,
and our NFL fan is flippin'
to female more than male.
- You know how political that's gonna be
to get distribution, right?
- Yeah.
- It's really political.
- It's really hard.
- You know the three tier system, right?
- Yeah, I came from Procter
and Gamble on the sales side.
So, I understand that side--
- The only difference is it's
actually completely different
than CPG from the standpoint
of the distributor
has the leverage, not the
creator of the product
because of the prohibition laws in place.
So, for you to, for the
San Francisco Giants
to serve it at their
Young's Market or Southern,
it's an extremely difficult business.
I just wanna make sure you're
goin' in eyes wide open
and not make too much the first year.
- Yeah, that's good.
John said the same thing.
- Good (laughs).
- Yeah, he is good,
and this Hustle Fest is
a brand-able thing too.
- It's a conference.
- Yeah, yeah it's a conference--
- Look, I mean it's all,
listen, you obviously,
I mean you can imagine,
based on what you just said,
how native this question is for me.
You know, I'm gonna
give advice that I think
that I live, which is you need to build up
as much personal brand equity as possible
to then funnel into these energies.
I believe the way to do that
is to invest in your personal brand.
That means produce content
and spend media to amplify it.
The biggest mistake people
are makin' right now
is relying on organic,
on their personal brand,
because that feels like
the right thing to do.
There's almost like this badge of honor
of they get their traffic from organic.
It's actually the reverse.
It's a super non-strategical move
to not amplify media,
when media's under priced.
- That's great.
- You should be spending as
much money as you can afford,
amplifying your content on LinkedIn.
- [Bryan B.] Are you doing anything
with legal cannabis yet?
- Yeah I have a 49% share in
a company called Green Street
out of Los Angeles.
We've taken some former
VaynerMedia employees
that now work in there.
It's an agency.
It's a conference business
called Hall of Flowers,
which we own a piece of
and we own pieces of
equity of brands we start
with other individuals.
- [Bryan B.] Have you heard
of Poppy Delivery yet?
- No.
- So they're, I'm invested in them.
It's a cannabis delivery
in Nevada and California--
- Yeah, which is exploding as
a business model everywhere.
- [Bryan B.] Yeah, so
we bought 150 smart cars
and started distribute them all
across California and Nevada,
and the interesting thing
now that we're up against
is obviously, you can't use Facebook.
You can't use paid search--
- Yeah, but that's sucks
for us 'cause we know it,
but I keep tryin' to, this is
literally my favorite thing
that's going on right now,
is the cannabis conversation of like--
- [Bryan B.] It's like before
Facebook and paid search,
there were other things.
- 100%.
- [Bryan B.] We'll just go find those--
- You could also do influencer marketing.
Yeah like, all my cannabis friends,
and since I'm really in it,
and you know, two years
ago, when I came into it,
there was a legitimacy factor
that the market appreciated
and I was like, look, it's
here's the punch line.
Everybody, I was just at the
Hall of Flowers conference,
every single person that
came up to me and said,
"Gary, what the fuck?
"I can't, Facebook's fuckin' me."
I'm like, they're not fucking you.
They have a term of service.
You don't think they want your money?
They're tryin' to figure it out.
So, instead of crying
about what you can't do,
why aren't you spending all your time
trying to figure out what you can do.
You can start the number
one podcast in the world
around cannabis and dominate.
This is gonna be great
for cannabis businesses
because the drug of the
current unbelievable
success of being sucked into
an Instagram, Facebook world
is something they're
not gonna get high on,
which is gonna allow them to innovate
and create something they own,
instead of fuckin' renting.
- [Bryan B.] One more
culture question for you,
if you don't mind.
So, I'm addicted to
starting new businesses.
They'll tell you that as well.
How do you make your current team
feel like you're not gonna
abandon them or is it--
- By not abandoning them.
- [Bryan B.] Well, yeah, but obviously,
but I mean they know
my personality by now,
but it's like,
"How do I, wait, less time of yours?"
- 100% what worked for me
is I would say things over and over.
They mainly didn't believe it
and then, overtime, as things happened,
they believed it more
and that's how you build a reputation.
- [Bryan B.] Yeah, makes sense, cool.
- It's funny how basic it is,
but what are you gonna do?
Hypnotize them?
(laughing)
- [Bryan B.] It's kind of a factor of--
- No, no, but I'm making a joke--
- [Bryan B.] people around you or--
- No, because it's still not you, right?
How do you make sure they know
that you're not gonna abandon them.
That doesn't come in
the form of hiring me.
Hey, I'm here.
That makes it seem like that
you're going to abandon them.
(laughing)
You know, like, here's Carl.
He's really important
and I'm like, "Fuck!"
This is the thing, you know?
I've gone the other way.
I've gone more in, you know?
I'm like literally,
I even unlimited the COO role at Vayner.
I'm the COO.
That really gets you to believe it,
when the COO operational, you know?
- [Vayner Employee] Both offices (laughs)
and an interview with CNN.
- [Gary] Okay, quick photos.
Yeah, let's do a quick selfies first.
Oh, thank you brother.
- [Bryan N.] Want your
present man?
- [Gary] Ah, this is fuckin' amazing, bro,
- Game worn, man.
- Game worn, fuck.
Dude this is amazing.
- [Bryan N.] With an
unworn hat, how's that?
You can take--
- [Gary] Awesome, I will, thank you.